community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
findlay automotive group the sponsors of
this next segment teamed up with subaru
of las vegas to give back to two special
organizations rocky joined them to help
share the love we are here at subaru of
las vegas celebrating cars and community
of course with findlay automotive groups
so tyler let's start with you you know
kind of tell us the mission behind you
know cars and community within the
automotive group well as you know we
support as a philly auto group we
support a lot of charities we're doing
it all the time and uh
finley's subaru of las vegas uh has an
annual share of the love event so subaru
has very much the same values as finley
automotive like to support the local
community so what we're here today for
is our share of the love event where
we're going to support two wonderful
hometown charities and we've got burton
hughes here our general manager and tell
you a little bit about the specifics
then we're going to present some money
to a couple of charities all right i'm
excited and burton i know share the love
is very very important to you this is
your 14th year of the event you guys
have given over or about 200 million
dollars to charities over the last 13
million as a
nationwide over 200 million locally uh
well over 200 thousand dollars you know
so yeah it's incredible that's
incredible and why do you guys do this
every year it really comes from the
heart of who we are as a brand subaru
and as findlay automotive you know and
and so suber of las vegas it's just
something that we look forward to every
year uh we participate uh not only at
the local level with our the sales of
our cars but also in our service
department everybody pitches in so that
we can really uh connect and support and
uplift our local community and our
partners out there doing the work every
day all right well then it's time to
give the first check that's right so
let's do our first one to redrock search
and rescue so uh let's see what we got
[Music]
twenty a little over twenty seven
thousand dollars
that is incredible so can we talk to can
we talk to you guys come on over come on
over do you see this amount how do you
feel
we are really stoked it's really awesome
and we love working with subaru in this
event
it helps us a lot it keeps us out there
looking for people
what are you guys going to do with this
money specifically this will pay our
operating expenses we have a lease to
pay utilities fuel in our vehicles and
equipment medical equipment and things
like that that we have no other funding
for okay so our second charity is the
just one project which great local
charity finley's been supporting them
for some time now but they do provide
great volunteer opportunities provide a
lot of food uh food pantries and
delivery to shut-ins and so forth so
great charity we love to support so
we're gonna present a little bit of
money to the just one project let's see
what we have for them
michael oh almost 27 000
i'm loving the confetti that's amazing
this is amazing so let me come over here
bring it on and you guys come in come in
come in i know you guys got a whole team
come on in come on in
incredible how do you feel well this is
our first time feeling the love from
subaru and we definitely feel it we're
just so grateful you guys this is
amazing and this is so incredibly
helpful to our mission well speaking of
your mission just tell us you know what
you guys are going to do with this money
specifically absolutely with this money
we're able to feed our community which
is what we do as tyler mentioned so for
us it's very exciting to be able to
partner with subaru to use these funds
to serve our community well
congratulations and congratulations for
your first time feeling the love
thank you again to findlay automotive
group for sponsoring this segment
kendall